>> WELL, PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS
BEEN ACTIVE ON TWITTER TODAY.
WHAT IS ON HIS MIND THIS FRIDAY?
IMMIGRATION.
DREAMERS, THEY MUST OKAY THE
QUOTE:
BRIAN, YOU ARE GETTING THE FIRST
ANSWER IN ALL OF THE BLOCKS
TODAY.
>> NOTHING THAT HE TWEETED IS
SURPRISING.
THEY MUST BE SAYING WHAT IS THE
BEST THING FOR US TO DO?
THEY WANT TO BE SUCCESSFUL IN
2018.
>> AND DACA MATTERS TO THEM.
>> A LOT.
SCHUMER TWEETED OUT THAT
DREAMERS ARE NOT A BARGAINING
CHIP FOR THE BORDER WALL.
HE IS SAYING IF YOU BRING UP THE
WALL, IT HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
DACA.
IF YOU DON'T PUT DACA IN THE
BUDGET JANUARY 19th, WE DON'T
PASS.
I SENSE AN EMPASSE.
UNLESS THE LEADERSHIP ON THE
LEFT -- BECAUSE I THINK
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS PLIABLE --
THE LEADERSHIP ON THE LEFT WILL
STAND TO SCHUMER AND SAY I KNOW
WHERE YOU STAND.
WE HAVE TO GET SOMETHING DONE.
THERE IS A BIPARTISAN COMMITTEE
IN THE SENATE.
JEFF FLAKE IS LOOKING
JEFF FLAKE -- BLAKIN
JEFF FLAKE -- BLAKEN
JEFF FLAKE -- BLAKE L
JEFF FLAKE -- BLAKE LOO
JEFF FLAKE -- BLAKE LOOKI
JEFF FLAKE -- BLAKE LOOKING
JEFF FLAKE -- BLAKE LOOKING F
JEFF FLAKE -- BLAKE LOOKING FOR
A COMPROMISE.
>> BLAKE TWEETED BIPARTISAN DACA
BILL ON SENATE FLOOR IN JANUARY.
HE BELIEVES THAT IS COMING AND
SOMETHING IN THE SENATE THAT
WILL SUPPORT A COMPROMISE?
DEMOCRATS CARE ABOUT DACA.
SOME REPUBLICANS DO TOO.
IT IS THE SAME THING THAT
PRESIDENT OBAMA SIGNED THROUGH
WITH THE EXECUTIVE FIAT WITHOUT
ARE THEY CITIZENS?
DO THEY GET A GREEN CARD?
LEGAL STATUS?
25 DAYS WE HAVE NOW TO GET THIS
DONE.
BRIAN, PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
MALLEABLE TO THIS.
IN SEPTEMBER HE TOOK HEAT
THESE PEOPLE.
LATER.
THAT I THINK DACA IS TOO
COMPLICATED TO PUSH THROUGH IN
AMERICANS IN FAVOR OF DACA
STAYING AND 63% OF TRUMP
SUPPORTER S
SUPPORTER
SUPPORTERS WANT DREAMERS TO GET
CITIZENSHIP.
>> I DON'T THINK YOU NEED PUBLIC
PRESSURE.
BOTH SIDES WANT TO WALK ON IT.
I WOULD RATHER SEE A BIPARTISAN
EFFORT WITH DACA THAN WITH
HAVE.
HERE THEY CAN COME UP WITH A
SOLUTION.
IT CAN BE A LITTLE BIT MORE
SUBTLE.
IT CAN BE MORE NUANCE.
YOU CAN OFFER CITIZENSHIP TO
UNIFORM AND THOSE IN LAW
ENFORCEMENT.
PEOPLE FIGHTING FOR AND
DEFENDING THIS COUNTRY.
>> THEY ARE SUPER DREAMERS.
IF YOU HAVE GONE TO COLLEGE AND
STARTED A BUSINESS, IF YOU HAVE
NEVER GOTTEN A SPEEDING TICKET,
THAT'S A DIFFERENT CATEGORY.
THAT'S WHY SO MANY PEOPLE ARE
SAYING THEY NEED TO DO
SOMETHING.
PUT SOMETHING TOGETHER.
STOP POLITICIZING IT.
IT'S A BARGAINING CHIP.
THE WALL IS IMPORTANT TO THE
PRESIDENT.
>> THE WALL IS THE ISSUE.
>> IF YOU WERE BROUGHT HERE AT A
3 YEARS OLD AND YOU ARE NOW 22
YEARS OLD, CAN YOU STAY?
THERE IS A PATHWAY TO
CITIZENSHIP FOR THEM.
WHAT ABOUT THEIR PARENTS?
THE ANSWER IS NO.
IT'S EASY.
NO.
>> NO!
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING]
>> GOVERNORING IS COMPLICATED.
DOES THIS GET DONE?
DOES THE WALL GET BUILT?
CHIP.
IT SOUNDS GOOD WHEN CHUCK
SCHUMER SAYS DREAMERS ARE NOT A
BARGAINING CHIP.
>> DEMOCRATS USED ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS AND THE DREAMERS AS A
CHIP.
THEY KICKED THIS OVER TO TRUMP
AND SAID HE DOESN'T HAVE A
HEART.
>> AND NANCY PELOSI.
>> THEY WERE NOT HECKLING MITCH
McCONNELL.
>> WHAT HAPPENS?
THE PRESIDENT SET THIS.
>> TAKE THE LIST, CHAIN
MIGRATION AND THE WALL AND
VETTING.
>> THESE ARE REAL PEOPLE.
800,000 DREAMERS.
IN MARCH THERE WERE A LOT OF
STORIES ABOUT SOME OF THEM WHO
ARE NERVOUS ABOUT THE FUTURE.
THEY HAVE FAMILIES.
>> TELL THEM TO MAKE A DEAL.
>> THEY WANT THIS BUDGET PASSED
MITCH McCONNELL SAID IF YOU GET
>> WHAT ABOUT THE WALL?
>> [OVERLAPPING TALKING]
>> IT'S AN ISSUE FOR DEMOCRATS.
>> YOU CAN TAKE DACA APART AND
SAY YOU GET CITIZENSHIP HERE.
THE SAME THING WITH THE WALL.
UNITED STATES.
A 90 MILLION DOLLARS WALL.
THAT COULD MEAN PART COULD BE
SURVEILLANCE AND PART A PHYSICAL